hi guys it's Greg here this jefita
editorial this is shara we're gonna
unbox something Warner Brothers sent
over some awesome crap to me pretty sure
they can cure you off the show no you
always got a shout and lower it in
iMovie
look at this badass plot except me wait
wait just start grabbing stuff make it
special
alright Warner Brothers consumer
products sent this over to me it's all
Wonder Woman goodies
he saw Wonder Woman he really liked it a
lot of a charge and Nazi Wonder Woman
but she waited outside for him while he
was watching Wonder Woman which was just
as cool of an experience for her I went
to the Wonder Woman remember I saw patty
Jenkins talk about it and that got a
super excited to watch it so let's start
on barely knowing I know don't forget to
say who invited you to that Oh
achar invited me to go watch The Wonder
Woman film and I said I'm surprised
Jabby didn't hit me up about this and
Trog like Greg I hooked up John and I
hooked up with Charles mm-hmm and
Courtney they don't know Courtney all
right let's see who am i flirting time
yeah usually it's like one date box in
the bag Wow Jami can you take a photo of
the bag look totally super gay on you
hashtag not at all against gays hashtag
no discrimination
let's open this bad yeah feels like
there's something in that
oh yeah open this way so they can see
okay wait I gotta read this I'm not
gonna be the whole thing this video is
hashtag sponsored and hashtag Wonder
Woman yeah there you go
what a brother's consumer products has
assembled this exclusive adventure pack
featuring the latest collectibles from
Warner Brothers pictures highly
anticipated action adventure film Wonder
Woman we'd love to see a video of you
unboxing all these goods once you in
vail all the contents and I picked our
favorite item please also create a video
about that as well
created in your own voice using your own
unique sense of humor sorry Captain Hook
die you art disaster the wrong hand
humor in total today if you decide to
make and share video please remember to
include a disclaimer stating you have
received the products from Warner
Brothers consumer products and Wonder
Woman for content creation purposes
finally please include the hash tags
hash tag sponsored and hash Wonder Woman
let's see what's in here oh my god
Barbie doll looks like a bee could you
take pictures there are so many
mentioning I wish I didn't tell people I
was getting this box because there's
like more than three people now who won
at least one item for me from his box I
have so many things I would do with that
that's ash tag not Furby block boy
you're supposed to be taking photos but
okay
Oh old man Wonder Woman oh that's cute
yeah wait wait
oh the wait will this fit me yes it will
fit me yes I might have lost 25 pounds
I'm not there yet for camera I'm
protecting your modesty don't worry I've
got you you're not doing anything I've
got you Oh
oh sweet this is sexy okay that took a
lot you got a lot of photos I want this
right here though this is my I want the
sword they'll go well with your bracelet
yes now I'm just kidding every day
it's just striving how I will hashtag
not perfect oh snap wasn't me try me oh
yeah oh yeah let's take it out sure just
look at bad on me sweet oh yeah that's a
good shirt I know what I'm wearing
thank you first people oh yeah oh sweet
hashtag one at the camera you can have
the sword
kind of don't want to give it up this
video system bunch of noise pretty sick
are you gonna use it dude I told one
girl I'm saying
that I would give her something give her
these bracelets what about me
you don't have a laptop bag you don't
need one maybe I need a laptop stickers
I just watched the video the other day
you said if you give away GoPro cameras
I was pissed yeah well you know what
that's what you do when you're desperate
for gifts for people that you really do
you have GoPros no I know that okay yes
oh yeah all right
yeah which one do you want okay whatever
you want okay there you go it started
that's so nice I want this bag how am i
giving the girl the sword no no give it
these give her those no that's a
collectible you keep forever
Greg wants them away though actually I
would keep that and give her this one I
think it's yours right cuz you can wear
these in other videos after your review
you can use these long man you're gonna
keep this one
we're give
girl that's posing in the crappy yes
yeah but you deserve a good gift all
right you can have the bag Greg's new
something like toy American sausage
holder we'll get this one
what hey she refers to be called penis
hole
all right well wonder woman goodies
hashtag sponsored hashtag Wonder Woman
you can subscribe to the real rejects
check out Jabby co-ed on the jab eco a
chance is soda Chara Kirk is a chart
occurred on the social media click that
notification bell hell's to the yeah
[Music]